I want to now actually talk about a special case which is Median Filtering.
Now averaging was, great to actually look at the neighborhood, and
figure out, a numerical value that's the average of the neighborhood.
But we can actually apply other statistical functions in here.
Of course we're going to play with Median.
Again, let's make, take my simple example.
My input image.
Look at my neighborhood of three by three.
And this time around, let's calculate its median, of this right three by three.
And again, what we can do is basically open up the whole matrix like so, and
show, the whole thing.
And of course, the median of this signal or
this neighborhood of nine by nine, oh, three by three, nine elements, is 20.
Just to, compare, the average of this signal is, would have been equal to 19.
So of course, just by doing median to, averaging, we have changed the intensity
value of that output that I want to put in the output image by one.
What we want to do again, just like anything else, is we want to run this
application and run it each and every,uh, pixel, rubbing it over
the whole image as we've done before to generate, of course, a median image.
So notice this is a little different.
We're not doing cross correlation as we did before.
For, we're not actually putting the elements in,
we're actually taking the element, nine by nine, and running a separate process,
a separate function on it to come up with a new value.
So we are no longer kind of doing the kernel, because in this case,
in median filtering, there is no kernel.
Kernel is actually a function, rather than an image.
Let's look at an example of how media filtering works.
So just to make sure we are clear median filtering is a nonlinear operation and
it's often used as a very strong tool in image processing.
And I'll show you examples of how actually, strong of a process it is.
Mostly what it is used, is to reduce noise, but other good things with it
as actually also preserves edges and sharp lines, which is a valuable thing.
And as I said previously a basically a median of all pixels.
Rather than using a kernel function as basically a stronger tool,
than just computing the average mean of that neighborhood.
And of course I showed you an example of just doing it over nine elements or
a three by three size window.
It could be again for larger things